it's great to have you here at letting
people come back up how are you enjoying
it today I'm really enjoying it it's
lovely to meet everyone and great to see
all the other guests and you know it's a
big buzz going around scrapes every one
of course always loves Doctor Who what
was it you enjoyed though about your own
character I left the fact that she was
she started off you know as a little
made quite a light and then as the
episodes went on you saw a different
side to it became a feisty and kick-ass
and you know she actually really cares
about the doctor and she became more
than just a maid tunic Madame vastra we
became a sort of double act and you know
rocked up to help the doctor out it's
just fun yeah we like a bit of kick ass
as well though yeah it's brilliant Anna
great to be in a leather cat suit to
that reveal and to do some stunts it's
good and when you do your character like
that do you kind of make a backstory for
yourself and maybe even a future story
too and try not to do a future one
because I suppose in real life you don't
really know what's ahead but yeah
definitely me and Nev we spoke about our
backstory and how we met and
how I plan to live with her figured out
kind of how we've met the doctor but I
suppose because it's Doctor Who time
travel and everything we'd only know
what's happened in between so tried to
figure out sometimes how we got to a you
know North Yorkshire and North North
England in the Crimson horror yeah I
think is important about my backstory
and only being an orphan and Madame
vastra family on the street yeah it's
fun so good I enjoy doing that as an
actress sort of creating a life for the
character I think it makes the
difference definitely on screen you can
see it now for suddenly losing our
present doctor in the near future what
was it like working with the doctor with
Matt it was amazing yeah it was great
because the first episode I had with him
I didn't have that much to do and then
the ones in the current series we had a
lot more to do and then he's just a very
generous and energetic person and as an
actor he's great to work with because
he's always giving a lot and changing it
up and has a lot of great ideas and yeah
you know really bounce off each other
well so yeah especially the Crimson
horror episode was great because we had
our own lots of our own little stuff
together so it was fun
you would you like to see as the next
doctor slows a speculation of quarter
bounces even like will it be a woman
baby just have this chat in the rich
acidic question-and-answer and Colin
Baker was there and he said he'd quite
like to see a woman and some people were
saying it would be controversial and
that it should always be a man I can t
say a name I think it should be someone
who you know is kind of unknown at the
moment maybe and it's an young actor or
actress you can bring something new to
the part because Matt's got such an
energy and it's really you know
obviously it does wonders for people's
careers it changes your life and I think
it would be a great opportunity for
someone whom we may not know and you
know get to know through the doctor
through their character what was it like
being part of Doctor Who in the 50th
anniversary years something quite
special amazing and I mean it was just
amazing just to be asked back to be
honest for not just one two three to be
the part the finale especially was great
he had that obviously leads on to the
50th and
yeahjust i realized doing conventions
like this and being on set how big it is
and how popular is so it's really really
special it we might ever see you back on
screen with the doctor at some point I
don't know I'd hope so be lovely took
for us to come back I think you know
we're always turn up to kind of help the
doctor now we've become his gang
obviously as much sleep even that
hopefully it'd be nice to come back and
meet the new doctor somehow yeah I'm
glad I didn't die so it's good
you